this is a compass it's just like any
other compass
it's got orienting lines a ruler a
rotating bezel
and a magnetized needle but do you know
what the most frustrating thing is about
a compass
it only points north but what if there
was a compass that could point to
something
way cooler like i don't know the nearest
slice of pizza
so that's my challenge wired has given
me three weeks to figure out how to turn
a regular compass
into a compass that points to pizza
it's beautiful if i say so myself oh
this is so cool
it's actually working to the pizza
by the way i'm joe grand i'm a computer
engineer hardware hacker and former
technological juvenile delinquent i
built my first circuit board when i was
10 years old
and i just love doing this stuff
successful so there's a few goals for
this project the most important one
is to actually build a system that no
matter where i am in the world it's
going to point me to the nearest pizza
place the second goal
is to take our mess of wires and
components and refine that into
something much smaller
more like an actual compass that we can
just walk around and use
the third goal is to make this thing as
simple as possible so you just push a
button and you follow the leds
there's two separate design aspects for
this project the hardware and the
software
[Music]
the core of the project is this little
module made by particle it's a
microcontroller module
and a cellular network interface module
in one this is going to control all the
other peripherals in our design and also
let us communicate to the internet over
the cellular phone network to get the
information that we need to point us in
the right direction we have our antenna
the next piece is our gps module gps is
pretty common these days it exists in
all sorts of different devices
like in your cell phone which is
probably how you're being tracked right
now
the next thing is a magnetometer this is
a digital compass
so it's going to measure the magnetic
field of the earth and tell me
my heading next we have our led
indicators of course no electronic
product would be complete without a way
to power it
so we have a small lithium ion battery
oh i didn't put a button but whatever
maybe i should get a button how can i
forget about the button
do i want laser missile or top secret
i'm gonna go with top secret
[Music]
so this board here is called a
breadboard it's basically a little board
where you can plug
components into it so it just makes it
really easy that when you're prototyping
you can take parts in and out as you
need to to
kind of get stuff working
i have these individual components all
plugged into the
breadboard and wired up at least in an
initial configuration i'm not exactly
sure how things are going to go
once i start writing the code but this
at least is going to let me get started
now i'm going to go take it over to my
other desk and start working on the code
but first hold on i gotta hack into the
gibson
move the satellites around and you're
done
so my plan now is to work on the code
and try to get each of the individual
components operating i basically have
some sample code that i'm using from the
open source community so code that other
people have written to support different
modules
taking that kind of modifying it
tweaking it for what i need and just
making sure that i can communicate with
each thing
at a low level error that's usually not
good
oh all right we finally have some
progress
leds turn on let go of the button
leds turn off so i have the led ring
working i have the button working
now i need to get the compass working
and the gps working and then the
cellular connectivity working so i can
communicate to the internet over my
microcontroller
i am still working on some code to get
the compass module
working i have a little debug terminal
over here too so i can
send messages from my microcontroller to
the screen so i can actually see like
what state of the system are we in so
right now it's just waiting for a button
press
so when i go and hit the button press
the system should start doing some setup
all right welcome to pizza compass the
leds turn blue just so we know that
we're in a different state when i let go
of the button the calibration will stop
let go of that and now we can see x y
and z values in micro
tesla these are basically just readings
from the sensor
of the magnetic field that it's reading
so if we actually spin the unit around
we can see those values change
now those values don't really mean much
to us right now
but what we're going to do is along with
our calibration values
calculate the actual heading of this
compass you know which direction is this
compass
facing taking boring numbers like that
and turning it into something useful
and then we're going to try to display
that as an led on this ring
code
so just taking some baby steps here i
added some code to
take the compass information and convert
it
from the magnetic sensor data into an
actual compass heading
and we can see down in our little
terminal window over here
that right now it's about 50 degrees if
i rotate my board
in a circle that's going to change the
heading
i wish this was more exciting reminds me
of the story when uh
well i won't tell you that one so this
is pretty cool i now took the heading
that we were getting
basically divided it by a 360 degree
circle to figure out which
of the 24 leds on our ring should be lit
up
as i rotate this board the led stays in
the same position
so it's maintaining its heading no
matter which way we're pointing
sort of like an actual compass compass
code
complete onto the gps
i know that the hardware already
communicates properly to
this particle cloud service but what i
haven't figured out yet is how i can
send a query with our gps coordinates
over the network to get the information
back about the nearest pizza place
here's what i'm thinking i'm going to
push a button on the compass that's
going to send my local coordinates over
the cellular network to particle
particle is going to take that send it
as a search query to google
with my coordinates and asking for the
nearest pizza place
google is going to respond with that
information send that back to me
i'm going to process it and that's going
to point us to pizza hopefully
because i'm hungry it's kind of funny
because being a kind of paranoid
old school hacker i tend to avoid google
services as much as i can
but in this case google just ended up
having the best results that we need
you know they offer their api to
basically let developers and let
engineers and let people
use their technology and use their
search engines without having to
physically type stuff in
they're kind of just contributing to
this general collection of internet of
things in this general
collection of cloud-based intelligent
computing so it's the google maps
platform text search
it's a certain service you can sign up
for with google so i just logged into
google sign up for the api
all you basically are doing is passing
in a query i put pizza
of course you could change that to
anything else you want because it's
google
and then the location so you'll pass in
the gps coordinates that of course we've
captured with our gps module and then
the key
which is your own private api key that
ties this request to your particular
account so of course
pretty much all of this is gonna have to
be blurred out
but if i go and paste this into
a web browser it's going to go to google
query from google
and get back in a json format
all of the search results so this is
basically given my location
searching for pizza what's around me a
lot of information is transferred
behind the scenes that we never see over
the internet is in formats like this
which is kind of cool
latitude and longitude that's what we're
going to end up grabbing from this
entire
blob of information that's what we want
to use so let's go ahead and press the
button
if we look on our screen we can actually
see sending request
so we are formulating a packet that we
need to send over to the particle cloud
and then particle sends it to google
so it's ending with our coordinates
along with some of the other information
that it needs there's a whole
kind of packet structure that we have to
send over to google
we already see data received so it went
over the network to particle
to google back to particle back to us we
can see here
gps coordinates and then the name of the
pizza place which is sunny's pizza
that's one of the few pizza places that
are around my house now that we have
that we can continue to take those
coordinates feed it into the
algorithm that has to figure out the
point to point location and direction
and all of that but the fact that
we can send data and formulate the
packet that we need and then get
information back
is pretty awesome i'm super excited
about that
[Music]
a circuit board is really a physical
manifestation of
an electronic product it physically
holds the components onto the board
but then it also provides the electrical
connectivity between all of the
components
[Music]
designing circuit boards is really like
creating art
and it actually is called artwork when
you create the circuit boards that's the
technical term is
is the circuit board artwork most of the
time though circuit boards are inside of
products they're not seen
so they're really designed and
manufactured to fit into an enclosure
to be easily tested to make it easy to
assemble
they're not really worried about
aesthetics and how it looks but that's
something where a lot of the stuff that
i work on
i don't put it in a housing i have the
circuitry exposed i want it to look
not really like a circuit but more of a
piece of the larger
project so i don't want it to just look
like a piece of electronics i spend a
lot of time
in the circuit board design tool which
is not intended to work
really with graphics at all to try to
make products that look cool
and it takes a lot of time takes a lot
of tweaking and trial and error to bring
in graphics and adjust them
and kind of fit well with the actual
required electrical connections but
that's really
to me is what's so satisfying about
creating a board is you put in all this
effort
into essentially a piece of art and you
can express yourself in different ways
through that medium and get something
back so it's a very
kind of special sacred process to work
on circuit boards
so here's a rendering from the circuit
board design tool this is the front side
of the board
i had added the artwork so now we have
all these artistic elements
we want it to look more like a compass
so we have the ruler
we have our compass rose down here this
is all going to show up
as uh immersion gold so this is gonna be
gold-plated
the gps is gonna go here the button's
gonna go here the leds will go here
the magnetometer right there in the
middle and then the back side will have
the other circuitry i thought that looks
pretty close to an actual compass
especially with the ruler
on here and everything i'm super excited
as far as production manufacturing of
circuit boards there are
hundreds of manufacturing facilities
around the world that will manufacture
your circuit boards
you basically provide them with a bunch
of design files called gerber plots
which is kind of a text representation
of your entire circuit board design
so i'm going to have a professionally
manufactured circuit board and then have
it professionally assembled as well
i might need to do some touch-up hand
soldering but if everything goes well
it's going to be manufactured
and assembled by machine and then sent
back to me
the first step is the raw material
selection then
it's time for drilling the drilled
panels are coated with a resist
those panels are then taken to a laser
plotter which burns an image
into the resist film then those panels
are placed into a special rinse
that removes all of the laser burned
portions leaving only the design that i
specified
for electroplating the boards are put
into special pulse plating tanks
the exposed copper and the drilled vias
are going to be plated which gives us
the copper connections
the next step is to etch off the copper
that was previously protected by the
resist film
that leaves only the copper traces on
the top and bottom layers that i've
designed the solder mask
is the black coating that i've specified
on my board they place the circuit board
panels onto a screen printer similar to
how a t-shirt is made
the assembly process is a little less
complicated but there's still
a number of steps
once the solder paste is applied the
boards then go to the pick and place
machine
the pick and place machine takes all of
the parts and places them exactly where
they need to go on the circuit board
they then go into a reflow oven it's
sort of like a giant cookie machine the
boards go in
follows a very specific heating profile
and it comes out at the end
a freshly baked circuit board after the
boards pass the 3d x-ray they go
to aoi automated optical inspection this
time the operator is looking at all the
components making sure they are soldered
down properly nothing sticking up just
to get that final
last step before the boards are cleaned
and sent on their way
for our board we need to go through an
additional assembly step because the gps
module
can't go through the wash so it has to
be hand soldered
there's a pretty clear difference
between the parts that i use for the
prototype and the parts that i use
for an actual production circuit board
build the main difference there is for
the prototype i was using
little modules sort of development
boards that are intended to make it easy
to connect to a prototyping board like
we did
run wires to it test all the different
features but i don't need
all of this stuff around it what i'm
using for the production build
is just the actual component itself
there are some
additional components i need for it but
i don't need that giant board with all
the pins and everything
so basically moving from modules that
are designed for development
into using the individual components
intended to be mounted directly onto a
circuit board
i heard a knock on the door
the package is here
this is it right here and spare
components
on the bottom oh i am nervous so many
layers it's like peeling an
onion so far so good holy moly oh that
looks so cool
so the compass in the middle the leds
along the side
our button to start our quest and send
the data over the internet
our gps module our ruler in case we need
to measure things
here is the connector for the particle
board
some of the discrete components and all
the traces are on the back side
assembled pizza compass board is done we
have three of them just in case
something goes wrong with one or two
but it looks amazing i can't believe how
fast we got these things back
we're good to go fingers crossed ready
to give this a try
[Music]
it's been three weeks since i started
the design and today is the final test
let's go find some pizza let's power
this thing up
plug it in right so first thing we're
going to see is the leds initializing so
we can make sure they work
now we're waiting for the connection to
the particle network the green
is looking for a gps fix so now we're in
the next state which is
that the compass is ready for
calibration i'm going to hold the button
down
and all the lights will turn on so now
we're in the calibration mode where we
need to rotate the board
in all of the different axes in order
for the magnetometer to read
all of the different values so we do it
in the x and the y
in the z so we push the button to exit
calibration now we're in our rainbow
color wheel this is just waiting for us
to push the button to start our quest
over to the pizza place
sending the coordinates waiting for a
response
[Music]
and now pointing the pizza so let's see
where this takes us
so looks like i have to go that way
i just reached my first intersection and
the compass is pointing
as the crow flies so unless i want to
walk through a whole bunch of backyards
i need to follow the roads
so it looks like i need to go right down
here
i can tell we're getting close because
the compass starting to
veer off of the straight and point more
towards the left so i think this next
block up here i'm going to turn
left oh this is so cool it's actually
working
let's turn left now we see green light
pointing straight ahead
[Music]
we made it to the pizza place the
compass works let's eat
oh thank you pizza i've been waiting
three weeks for this pizza
oh look at that so there you go
that's the pizza compass yes it's a
little bit cheesy
yes there's other ways to reach the same
conclusion
uh but that's the beauty of engineering
taking something that's in your head
and turning it into reality my real
reason for doing projects like this
is to put them out in the world and see
what people do with them the project is
fully open source
so you can look at the hardware design
you can modify the code to do whatever
you want
this is just my interpretation of what a
pizza compass can do you can refine it
to do whatever you want maybe change the
leds for different animations
change the battery consumption to make
it last longer or even have it point
somewhere different
the point is you can learn from it and
do whatever you want with it
this project wouldn't have been possible
so quickly without the contributions of
the open source community
people who designed the software
libraries people who worked on the
hardware modules
if i had to do all of that from scratch
it would have taken me a few months of
effort
if not more let me know what you think
about the project in the comments below
what would you point it to